[Laughter]
[Music]
turning deficient vixx's ideas transfer
learning and all these things in one
piece really building presentations and
a good presentation and the idea for a
long time was the high levels of
participation correspond to two concepts
allows Olivia to stand the world and
explain things in the world and in the
kinds of notion that we communicate with
language concepts that happen to be
objects
think about ages think about actions and
so on so surprised what I'm here to do
how do we extend it will give deep
learning discovered cause the variables
and we cover as well they're called
which is cause which is affected how
they relate with each other but hugging
related each other we kind of already
know is entered machine running regular
little institution in Java solutions but
just cause of music is a question that
hasn't received that much attention
yet in machine learning on the fourth of
July and especially running and and the
other error which seems orthogonal
question this is also the ing scenario
where is you would in theory is that the
camera will come from the same
distribution of the training data and
everything you know
all right relationships and of course
[Music]
your assists make sense of they is very
very different from our training today
how do we protect ourselves into mental
simulation of what would happen
what we do that is if you have good
ideas got lots of physics Tom these
whether physical changes but could
potentially exist not an elbow at it and
[Music]
so this is something that's missing
right now but she got me this ability to
take the dollars in half and transport
it to scenarios unlikely under the
training distribution but humans do it
all the time counterfactuals are about
imagining situations which has not
happened will not happen
we pretend it could happen or they
couldn't have happened and we got some
antics very often is something physics
but somebody like better shopper I have
known for many decades and has been
spending the last decade and I talked
about him that way is boom and in one of
the ingredients in his book that has
influenced me the most is this idea of
independent mechanism so so so it's not
just that we have a bunch of module that
each capture different aspects of the
world and that there can be composed to
explain the data but it's also that each
mechanism is independent ticket
information theoretical sets one way to
think about it is if you have travelers
describe each of these
but they don't depend on each other
other words only crammed into one module
that's a video and the flip side of that
is that if somebody changes one of those
modules the other modules don't change
and this is crucial for machine learning
and this is the this is this is the
thing that I think you've got right can
we exploit this notion of independent
chasm to do priors data we want a chance
to learn that will help these agents
cope with changes in distribution and so
if we want to code changes distribution
with asti patties with changes in those
mechanisms we're gonna need to make
assumptions right the assumption that
the test data analyzed the same
distribution of trinka that isn't valid
anymore and maybe theories we deal with
not and those theories are going to have
to rely on assumptions right otherwise
the new distribution could be anything
there's no reason to believe that we'll
get any kind of transaction we need to
make some sort of early rod de sumption
that hopefully work well in the real
world and the assumption that I'm
proposing in this world is that the
changes that are going to happen most of
the time involved various human Academy
okay and we're gonna find out a bit work
oh and why is that a reasonable well
ages you would all right agents cannot
change the world in arbitrary ways
because they have limited temporal and
spatial extents by I didn't know the
things around me it's hard for me to
move the Sun it's hard for me to change
your brain that's exactly right now you
know at once
and so the world tends to change in the
sparse ways but when I say sparse I have
to also say naturally what space right
and so the right space or thinking about
sparsity of changes in distribution
isn't like physical space it is the
space of these high-level
causal variables base of these two
didn't even count isms which help us
explain how the world works okay this is
me the heart about my top that really
explaining this data now and then we
could go a little bit deeper to give
some meat around this but that's the
idea really central idea this work is
that it would by this assumption maybe
know any might be all about assumption
there's the new village theorem says
there is no algorithm that doesn't do
maybe assumption doesn't mean the
assumption we'd like to have a subject
that is Geralyn draw possible and that
we're willing to be verbs in this planet
for many many tasks where is the
possible machine learning is a devout
assumptions about the distribution of
the data changes do you do whatever
could be that there are no guarantees
these come from their non stationarity
is because agents intervene in the world
I said earlier it could also be
histological dangers like because I
discover the world my my mental
understanding the world changes you know
I visited you I there are changes in the
distribution as I encounter new things
you go to a new country you learn a
language in this region things here
you're seeing
Changez right but those changes are
small in the right space of
representation if you go to a new
country everything you know about the
world mostly each day is the same
now you have this sort of traditional
knowledge the culture and the language
of God people okay so now I'm gonna
sumption about changes of the tribution
smaller Templeton XD with adapting to
that change in distribution so you have
say a learner that has seen data from a
distribution then the world changes you
distribution but it's a small change in
the purpose additional space and if the
murderer adopts this assumption and has
the right representation space then the
learner will benefit by requiring less
data to lead to good dilation special
cases why it's obviously true and then
we'll go applying these ideas in context
of kazaar but before I hope they have
the triggers will be tracking each other
in some ways and speed and then reaching
teenagers and one of the nicest changes
you observe the things that have
different characteristics in the blank
space what was amazing is that this
graph is changing but in the observable
space like pixel space it might be a
huge change so here right now the eyes
are open eyes to all of you both of you
and then a close by eyes pixel wise it's
a complete different story but
in a lot of high-level spacious prints
only one thing change
close my eyes has eyes and you know
being is really useful hi little Bible
for me to follow them because I can
explain something loops are contrasting
with one bit do these are the kind of
the high level variables we want to look
at the back because it's going to
localize the change and it's going to
allow me to ompletely adapt to that
change I don't need to read let me do
distribution video just learn them this
is my ID clothes don't you changed it
before I go deeper I like to give you a
chance to do baby ask questions or
comment and look at ton at the end as
well be but I want to make a positive
because I'm introduces by really the
basic idea as if people have comments or
questions I know they're wrong
yes yes so very much and have usually a
terrible extent and and so you're like
my internal model will includes time I'm
thinking about things that will happen
in the future things of having fantastic
events yeah time is part of what we're
models this is another factor than being
absolute is in thanking factor you think
it's possible that these could be well
so causal factors is a technique factor
so so what we're trying to separate out
the knowledge with this and and and if
we wanted my solution like numbers of
these pieces we think about parables I
believe that many of these variables
have to do with causal fact so what is
it
it's something that is either a constant
in fact in the cause-effect relationship
not every number we manipulate naturally
get the status of being causal variable
pixels of that image are not really
popular cause of rifles and Lessing you
think of the whole images being like the
effect of some process but like
individual pixels really it doesn't make
much sense to talk to them as cause
right so so there are one of these that
we make up or I mean that maybe even
exist if you think that mean Queen dot
deserve to be called cosmic rifles and
maybe he did not look at one of these
that even you believe would have that
status for example the story one of
these we use for doing inference about
all the variables you might not want to
talk about them as causal variables but
but just pieces of the computation the
procedures and be decomposed into pieces
and it's a different type of cradles yes
[Music]
has to do what would be the effect now
knowing whether these cause of me or
because of a would be two different
dimension would have a different
consequence depending on which we want
to
[Music]
somebody believes I'm gonna do learning
research that trying to be Edison
tabular as possible when you deploy an
application people use as much knowledge
and when you do research that's gonna
have a big impact the losing for this
little doll is possible that's why I'm
making that these entities are the
impact effects so if I discover how you
can figure out disease this much more
profitable benefit I have a program
mmm hand fighting you know use of
physics if you can write and off against
[Music]
interpretation so these variables or
computations
depending on with the use of these ideas
but the main point is the knowledge is
represented as the combination of these
pieces and those pieces can interact in
the case that have been explored now the
nodes are actually the variables and the
[Music]
visual experience but the decision the
consequence of us being exposed to
richer data and I didn't understand
[Music]
essentially consume at least where this
is a directed rifle model and the
intervention how my translation is going
to be the muna consider specialty is now
and mostly for the rest of the talk the
composition even the probability of
everything
given its parents we're gonna have
separate parameters of each of these
conditional probability distributions
and we're going to consider these
they're one were small set of these
conditionals have changed and then then
I have this really wrinkled theorem that
says okay it's like a very very simple
consequence you need that we what we
learned and the changes so now here's
the joint the couple's conditional it's
critical that the gradient will be from
zero for the others
okay so here's like a special case
consider two variables EMP and there's a
joint one of the directions to respond
to the direct causal graph so say a is B
and now if we change the car we change
its market and the condition doesn't
change and my advice 0 that's just as
earth in the illustration of what I mean
very simple theorem what it means though
is of all the parameters I have you were
those that were wanted to modify
ovules - look there's another fewer of
those modules will need to be adapted
and the others will get a gradient
because if you don't know which module
has changed but the ones that have
changed will have like a significant
radium the others will have a gradient
which averaged to zero so there was some
boys will have a significant gradient
and so one defective number of degrees
of freedom that need to be adapted for
that change will be small but that's if
we have the impose enjoining hit the
graph right if we have the component of
the wrong way we might not be headed
from this this so if you have the volume
factorization give me has given me now
that happens is if we change giving both
will need to change deal with a change
in pH this is just a consequence of base
theory that given a and you see that the
way the indicated it could be have
changed and I'm now going to make
another plane now this sort of situation
that that was treated to these officials
and the case where I don't have the line
factorization of knowledge and which
parameter is going to need to change
whether to deal with the change and
claiming that this is almost the global
in standard real dance
that when you
that's her value when you have domain
chain when you consider probably against
traffic or getting in all these
denominators where the species change it
would rather the Deveny of all deaths
could not believe once participated in
minimizing the error and so you will not
have this fast a patient that I might be
talking about that would your mouth of
having the right your net architecture
that somehow physical underlying
structure of the the causal
relationships okay so I'm tweeting is
making progress
this issue of the mantras and coverage
could help us seems like every day for
the next verb difficulties comes in
learning an adaptation many things that
really matter it applications of machine
learning and where we see machine
learning systems break down when you
show them examples that are somewhat
unlike the training data for a human is
obvious what the answer should be so we
can test it we can test this idea that
he's waited going to have the right
factorization of knowledge here the
right factorization be learning the
earth this is the rate of adaptation the
way that the learner adapts how facet of
these numbers and needs to get a good
performance it's going to be very
different from if you have the loan
package where you want to model the one
that factorize with a PDA or is just
their goal for visiting the same Tron
distribution but with a different way of
factorizing two point right if you if
you just consider your training data and
training the solution those model will
behave exactly the same but when you
consider the scenario
we're trained them and then you consider
it modified stream of data and you love
learning with that by online because the
gradient descent you see that one that
responds to the correct factorization
the one that matches the underlying
causal structure and that's a large test
set from the light of life and you see
on the x-axis the example of the
diffusion so after 20 members yeah fully
adapted please be welcome and after hand
report a few hundreds of examples in
fact as I said earlier if you have
enough data it doesn't matter what the
factorization is really shocking is
compared to the model that has the wrong
yep every bus does this graph whose this
isolation rules
I think it's pretty robust me to try
this and many other settings and I don't
think it's the mission but it's a good
question
this is related to the work that has
been done by Karen and students and talk
about this I think you know another
t-top the question of systematic
realizations so this is something that
comes up in linguistics and humans have
an ability to generalize out of the
train distribution in particular people
we combine linguistic concepts that they
have seen in the training data
I can even teach you words you
us to a human and they'll be able to
naturally draw eyes from combinations of
bees that have never seen before and
that the house is your mobility under
the train distribution whereas different
new hat architectures will behave very
differently with respect to this stuff
of the architectures they considered in
this paper basically fails to do this
systematic transition where some
architectures did very well but
unfortunately both of the different
types of architectures did about the
same on the training distribution so
just thinking a test error doesn't
always tell you what the right of
authorization of knowledge is because
the tests distribution is from the same
distribution as the training set the
same test said this was in okay so what
we proposed to do in this paper we could
just do model selection like you could
say it changed the distribution see how
different models perform configure one
that adapts faster and we could create
some objective and measures rises like
some sort of area under the curve or
whatever or did it error right so we
couldn't do model selection but well if
you're doing model selection believe
you're optimizing think of this as
leader now defining a new objective
function which is how fast you adapt the
changes in distribution philosophy
that's the practical message of this
work that we would like to define new
types of objective functions that makes
sense when the learner is faced with
changes in the solution and the
objective is to maximize the speed at
which the learner adapts and guess
results right to you distribution and
it's different it looks like it's almost
the same as what we've been doing but
it's not right it's not and I give you
an example of that it's not when I
showed that on the training distribution
day the two models behave the same but
on the model my distribution one of them
adapts faster and if I give them enough
data of modified distribution people
behave the same again so there is
something special that happens in the
early stages of learning where there's a
lot of simple about what is the right
way of factorizing knowledge so this is
fundamentally different from what we do
I noticed a just optimized transition
error or optimized training here this is
the third thing which is optimized eat
an application to the changes of the
yeah so the gender distribution lead
with the training set so how can we
measure this generalization is noon of
generalization you're actually a really
good question
okay so when we do I can pick
experiments that we control completely
of course but that's not there because
we really want to do we need to think
about where this was five I think trust
both of these scenarios multitasking
scenarios I think that where you can go
it may look like there's only one
solution the fact that the agent is
learning with it and it's breeziness
knows about it over the presence of
other agents kinky things in the
environment couldn't be to these changes
really I don't
your answer to your question and I think
is something I will need work in many
different areas eat how does this idea
can be applied in practice what a cuss
tree for a curriculum thank you good
examples of the sacred cows together and
then make the big algorithm treatment
very simple example successively they
always get a shape in the distribution
whereas the same so I think in our local
cases so people who are instead of
shopping all the data from genes mass
the normally do things it is to get
better mileage but it's cheating
because the next thing that has become
could be from a spot integrity solution
so we should be not destroy the
non-stationarity we should exploit it is
only being used and kind of try to
destroy the ivory but we should and now
in different learning scenarios and
equations
I guess the agents are seeing are we be
very very stable and probably this is
not going to help much but maybe but you
think about ages that purposely change
things in the world to create changes in
distribution and I think humans do that
babies in particular experiments which
is also a scientist I think lyric
rapture trillions of perturbations that
is usually purposely to get access to
information that explains the world ever
okay
the things that I would like to optimize
with this objective there are these two
things what is the definition of what
the
because as I said in the real world
we're gonna get those pixels or sensory
data and not the variables in which it
makes sense to talk about cause and
effect so calls a week and so we want to
learn the causal graphs or the graph
here isn't the distribution it shows the
fact that it's a you know a discrete
entity that says these are causally via
a sees a good cause of B and whatever so
there's a graph and so that's it
discrete laughs okay so now that I go a
little bit quickly on experiments we did
on this very very simple poly a simple
scenario where you have two variables
before Isis the other way and now
increase the double study
doughnut-eating that's gonna capture the
solution of how fast were nervous gasps
chosen so the accumulated like you have
to get after each example so we're safe
online setting this is the usual thing
the only difference for the
useful like Judas remember the drivers
keep changing
okay so the plan is going to be burned
is beautiful by Capt person whatever you
want
I'm not lying the Katzenberg you look at
the COS theta okay but the parameters
and change anticipation process but
neither the divine are which really is a
meta learning objective right it's not
an objective for me it's an objective
for figuring out what America should be
and whether I should believe that is
console video or bees a cousin I don't
we get a measure that they should be
called regret and immigrants might as
well that will be still be ready the
regret of the mixture a special kind of
mixture between two hypotheses one
episode this is this is a stadium
doesn't learn and absolutely distances
and the second phase of training voting
we train now is new data and as you have
examples so this whole thing is a
measure of a lot of the discrete
hypotheses about on this episode which
is one example we get this for each
example we will have reproduces gamma
which is going to measure our belief
about which hypothesis is right or wrong
we want to make bone changes on this
gamma so that will converge to the
correct belief and so we take that
belief like and then we use a sequel to
give it the weight
[Music]
the controls how much we change again
because the so these are just
ingredients and now it's quite
interesting here ever that says that if
we do stochastic really descent on this
parameter using the subjective also this
this regret it objected and we too many
video editors won't get one anywhere the
end if we converge the fist a treaty
with the Sioux have increasing work
whereas one then convert the right way
that's that's assuring and then we
didn't have a bunch of experiments to
validate these ideas or something then
still purpose
and they will respond to keep calm
accreditations of the conditionals the
marginals for the joints out of the
simplest experiments are the tabular
parametrization so it's just that a to
be or discreet and you have a table for
P of a and a table for Quixote for table
from QT given epsilon and we do
stochastic descent on these parameters
and then browse the show you have an x
axis in episodes like the meta examples
[Music]
update of the gaba or whatever
underneath is being optimizing the space
with you letter to the post and we see
that 80% of race and dishes for example
we find which is really interesting is
that capital n is the number of values
that the discrete values have who has
any person so if you have two variables
and be the tabular representation will
be N squared parameters or the
conditional and any parameters for the
module right and in Nice Kicks where the
intervention is on the cause we may need
to change the Marvel which has n degrees
of freedom and we need to change the
conditional which has the N squared
profit that's if you have the right
model if when you have the wrong model
as I said earlier if you think is mixed
so go to change n script rather its
order than in spectrometer and so that
comes up in the speed of adaptation the
so that we see this really funny thing
is each you have too many crackers
you're gonna be good fitting but you
don't have a lot of data each of these
episodes is like looking at five or ten
examples and so people a situation where
the new distribution you know you don't
have enough data for it that's the
scenario where you get the most signal
about what the correct model is even
steny convergence to which which is
caused which is effect is extremely fast
compared to the case where you have all
these and promise I mean adverb and
value so you got borders and squares
about 100 problems so this is cool right
because the things that are going to be
that for learning like not enough data
too many parameters changes the solution
all these things that what have you
figuring out what's the right
modernization of knowledge Thanks so the
things that are interesting machine
learning become a training symbol for
these meta parameters which tell us
about things like what is the underlying
we good way of representing the
knowledge where the right variables
which one is causally - effect now these
are two experiments and I'm claiming
these things but a little how I verify
we're long but this is my intuition for
what is not so we've done with many more
experiments where the conditionals could
be MLPs and again we see the same kind
of thing that we can we can train these
things and it's working also for near
the awesome conditionals
is writing for a nonlinear multimodal
distribution for the conditions which
means it's flying and up to now I will
show the keys where
very most amv were fully absorbed but
we've also got experiments where you
don't observe the MV v X 1 and X and
lambda W obtained by the ground in B but
there is some transformation here we
just did that with your transformation
[Music]
[Music]
look at X Y this will be here compact
but if I enter it would lead to fast
medication in the UV space and the
transformation that the encoder has to
do in order to be too fast a patient's
rib joint entering this really simple
case to travelers one for the encoder
which is rotation and one for the
calibration and so we see both America
version at a reasonable pace most of
that is in which is online since I guess
it is about that line and more recently
doing a few things so the most pressing
is does this keep working with more than
two variables we also need to generalize
the objective function formulation
[Music]
[Music]
and then there was no blankies were each
additional each other
and that's what we do what are the
inputs can make it each additional so
you end up with one for every other
variables that are the server's of these
parents between the current
hypotheses and the objective 1 we can
rewrite it so we get more efficient this
is easy to estimate by sampling we're
jointly is the the inputs where the
deposit varies for each of those stuff
so we can do for each traditional we
want to know which you know the other
variables are going to be the cause of
parents and we can tell these doses each
conditional and still get good estimator
yeah so there's no there's nothing
listen about that assumption in what
we're optimizing but if there is no
possible in the change then there will
be no signal all right so the assumption
is not something you actually use in the
algorithm is robust to for example if
the change is focused on one variable
there will be a stronger signal then if
it's over the place is that yes so for
example in fact and we're starting to do
is trying to do inference when you know
these variables you can do the
parameters that end up leading to much
more stable convergence
oh yeah yeah I think this is this is
something that means a lot
our expiration we consider the case
where the learners be agnostic about the
change but it makes sense given the
hypothesis that the learner would go one
step further they well they guess which
very little changed it was a very strong
signal about that which of the
conditionals God lakeview which was much
worse than what it used to get so
there's a variable that you go for did
with them well it's probably the
variable that has changed so you know
it's like easy information there we
should be able to eat so we've
experimented the different easy unions
of causality that people study can any
covered by those names I would like you
I guess it's over even 30 but I would
like to use a little bit of a time
interval beginning to connect that with
other things that I think we've got that
concerns of other hypotheses dollars
done Joint Distribution between the
latent variables and how we do that job
putting pressure of the learner to
discover the light and those Hydra
members have to do with something that
has been one of the top and weaknesses
of deep learning up to now which is what
is a logical system types of ignition
system one is intervening as well right
now which we say and you can do very
quickly and accurately how we're system
is what we usually consider like the
reasoning the thing is conscious
sequential approximate that we know that
our simple rules expected well they're
not perfect but really cool things like
counterfactuals and give scenarios and
that's very quickly what the possibility
I and so I think that making progress on
these high-level vehicles and their
relationships touches upon the question
of what we should do it's usually part
of this discrete but I actually think
that the animals have a lot of variables
don't think about geometry think about
the shapes of things these are and be
very high-level things I visualize I
think I'm a visual person and I see
continues rebel all the time in my mind
not just discrete ones ok so the
consciousness prior chooses a year and a
half ago in the in the context
everything I've said today then he put
it this way
in the context of everything exit today
amounts to simply saying don't
description people are Hydra variables
is this so the factor graph is a way to
represent from distributions in which we
separate the joint potential functions
each of these functions only into
subsets of areas as far as that stuff
set and what did you understand what
that means the thing about rules in
classical AI rules and facts like your
classical stuff right that will never be
forced to accept if you are my age or
something
basically each of these rules is about
before right things think of
these practices you know these
configurations of variability and other
configurations that contradict the role
have a loop and so not envy them is that
the potential in a factor graph
formulation in fact it's not something
I'm making omits it's been studied by a
lot of people already the publication of
movies this is a natural assumption and
the dependent consciousness is simply
not the things that down to our
consciousness are involving variables at
a time so it would be one of these
factors or a couple of these factors
that interact about your conscious self
at a particular time that you love you
know in order to the game villain that
would need something like that attention
they can ism database so that episode of
articles do special things that the
conscious state that would be very very
long and that level representation dot
mean we humans do things like planning
and imagination right the future or the
past to try to respect the past isn't in
this piece of pixels and it isn't them
visiting the space where the key be
relevant are activated or I think I'm
lying
we only focus on a few variables of a
time when when I when I hit you just go
what I think about the pathway all I
only go through very intercepts each of
these steps
certainly ignores almost everything but
we all these few elements that matter
than my plan so I think we should
increment and now for this to work I
need to have these representations which
select the subscribe
and want to say something about the
world about things that have happened
and things like that
yeah just skip to thing stuff but he
should be done boys planning or each
time to figure out part of that is where
to go when you want to explore what are
the interesting things that an agent
could do in order to learn more about
will have a causal hypothesis and maybe
there's you know some variables which I
have a lot of certainty which is
constant fact well maybe that's a good
place to experiment I like to test
whether a is a cause it's a cause thank
you really see that if I intervene a lot
if it doesn't that means that it wasn't
the cops right and vice versa so so this
is very very useful information
information that I'm proposing is very
useful information for an exploration
college being working with you know
three or whatever and articles but the
realities of interest this is worth
pointing out right here is things like
agents in some situation where the
exchange where you know it wouldn't be
able to deny even with what we actually
think you're not there yet there there
audience respect
to the meta learning objective but as
usual with mental earning it comes with
all kind of foreheads so either you have
continue striving but the endures in two
years we have a drop 20 updates as he
was living in like mamble out of it
learning methods but I don't like it for
some reasons like it's very here
I don't think frightens do that so any
case it's also confidentially expensive
very expensive because you have to
remember it could be 95 more efficient
way of doing and then of course they are
discrete variables like the grass
culture honey now this tastes better but
it's like a limp or satirically my boys
there's going to be done on Camillo
catalyst invaders or gradients or
updates as per to these objections
this is I think a lot of interesting
theory to do do justify this approach
generalize it and it better and now we
can consider very simple scenario where
well you train and then we have a stream
online of things I think this thing like
these we were completely on the line
reading setting but that needs to be
work done and then I mentioned earlier I
thought useful to indifference in that
particular about the interventions
themselves and that will change the game
I think there's a potential for even
more reduction complexity one of the
agents starts to reason about the
interventions so this thing can be
really useful or catastrophic forget it
after forgetting as an artist the worst
distribution a and B even Cienega t if
the learner you strike above understood
there's a change but I'm going to label
the first part that they are eating
third part of see when I get to see
examples that are pay by recognizing
this a and I can do that birth weight
and I can much faster if I just do
inference in other words examples after
I've seen enough inked in the world I
don't need to learn any more I just
figure out what who did what right
that's what our brain does a little who
did what and then we don't actually need
to learn something in France about
colleges okay so all that inference
stuff I think is nice graduation so
you're a bunch of people is that these
right now here even happens I haven't
talked about yet so thank you very much
more questions